le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
préserver des vies stopper des feux ou
encore protéger les populations autant
de missions qu accomplissent
quotidiennement les sapeurs pompiers
principalement masculin les effectifs
accueille de plus en plus de femmes
rencontre avec tiffany nadine deux
jeunes recrues investi dans ce travail
pas comme les autres
[Musique]
à la caserne du tampon tiffany entame sa
garde
elle vérifie et prépare le matériel qui
lui servira sans doute à sauver des vies
une vocation pour cette recrue
volontaire tu es infirmière depuis
presque dix ans j'ai toujours travaillé
à l'hôpital
et depuis maintenant un peu plus d'un an
je suis infirmière chez les pompiers
donc je fais ça sur mon temps de repos
en tant que pompier volontaire tiffany
doit alterner entre ces deux casquettes
je travaille à l'hôpital je travaille en
douze heures de 7 heures à 19 heures et
le lendemain je travaillerai nuit donc
de 19h à 7h ensuite j'aurai trois jours
de repos et je recommencerai jour nuit
donc sur ces trois jours de repos je me
rends disponible pouvoir prendre des
gardes
souvent on va me demander mais s'est pas
fatigué tu t'arrêtes jamais bah en fait
non parce que j'aime réellement ce que
je fais est en fait venir en garde on
pourrait penser que ça crée une fatigue
supplémentaire mais au final c'est
enrichissant et du coup la fatigue on la
ressent pas assez pour moi c'est un
plaisir en fait devenir un métier
enrichissant qu'il était une évidence
pour la jeune femme suit pompiers parce
qu'enfin c'est quelque chose que j'ai
toujours connu en fait j'ai grandi dans
les casernes de mon père était pompier
et c'est quelque chose qui a toujours
fait partie de
deux mois en fait donc pouvoir moi à mon
tour entré chez les pompiers bas c'est
une certaine fierté et du coup je sais
que mon père est fier aussi de dire
voilà ma fille elle suit la même voie
être une femme dans celui du très
masculin pour tiffany loin d'être une
difficulté c'est parfois même un
avantage par rapport aux gens je pense
que le fait d'être une femme dans
certaines situations et ben en fait ça
peut apaiser les maux seront
différents et parfois si la victime est
une femme surtout elle peut se sentir
dès fois plus à l'aise femme pompier
elle aussi nadine partage son temps
entre la caserne de saint pierre et le
ct un centre de traitement de l'alerté à
saint denis les vamps et je vous écoute
bonsoir il tient pas debout fnac aurait
il est là les yeux ouverts ou fermés
monsieur là on a eu un appel pour un
malaise sur la voie publique
on envoie une ambulance sur de
saint-denis voir ce qui se passe
exactement demandes de secours incendie
ascenseur bloqué fuite d'eau les tâches
ne manquent pas pour les
sapeurs-pompiers et c'est ce qui fait le
sel du métier le fait de porter secours
d'être ou même de donner à quelqu'un au
téléphone qui permettra beauté des
choses une vie donc il ya toute cette
partie là qui fait que même c'est le
sait le prêter en six ans qu'on retient
de le savoir si on a servi à quelque
chose on a été utile à la population un
travail gratifiant mais avec un haut
niveau d'exigences auxquelles hommes
comme femmes de ce clip
au niveau du sport il faut être il faut
est aguerri il faut être prête
mentalement physiquement
donc c'est un utile voilà il n'ya pas de
distinction entre l'homme et la femme
quand on est en uniforme c'est pour moi
c'est un pompier pas une femme et un
homme
c'est vrai qu'à l'époque il ya une
dizaine d'années et les femmes étaient
est pas tout à fait reconnu comme
aujourd'hui donc il a fallu montrer
qu'on était là qu' il y avait
on est aussi capable comme tiffany
nadine rêve d'être pompier depuis
l'enfance tout avait commencé comme je
le disais le tarn il
des 14 juillet auquel j'ai pu assister
que j'étais beaucoup plus jeune j'ai vu
les camions rouges comme tous les
enfants avec la regarde enfants tous les
camions rouges et aujourd'hui ça m'a
voilà ça m'a donné envie de 2,2 tout
faire pour réussir à devenir pompier le
14 juillet est une date importante pour
nadine qui a vu naître sa vocation
c'est donc avec fierté qu'elle porte
cette année les couleurs des sapeurs
pompiers dans une section exclusivement
féminine une reconnaissance publique
pour ces femmes qui ont ouvert la voie
soutenu par les départements les femmes
s'engagent de plus en plus dans des
métiers qui parfois été considérés comme
des métiers d'hommes mais elles ont les
capacités physiques mais encore les
intellectuels pour le faire donc on ne
doit pas empêcher ce mouvement au
contraire doit l'accompagner et dans les
femmes s'engagent dans des métiers et
sapeurs pompiers je dirais que c'est
aussi important au niveau de
l'encadrement
parce que nous avons besoin de cette
complémentarité hommes femmes dans ces
métiers liés à la sécurité
[Musique]
l'usld 10 de la réunion gère les
différents sapeurs pompiers de lille il
est composé des sapeurs pompiers
professionnels du personnel
administratif technique et spécialisé et
des sapeurs pompiers volontaires sur les
2300 91 personnes qui composent
l'effectif global 306 sont des femmes
chez les sapeurs pompiers professionnels
5% de l'effectif et féminin pour plus de
renseignements rendez vous sur le site
du département au www.desjardins.com 7,4
points fr lien social accompagne le
réunionnais pour la mobilité
la mia l odre ramsamy il ya trente ans
mais il est né dans les hauts de sainte
marie mais depuis dix ans
bien vite et hasani plus précisément au
chaudron on a un bep et un bac pro de
comptabilité que m'a fait au lycée du
parc
mais là je suis hôtesse commercial
principalement je fais de l'accueil est
aussi une partie location de cd en moins
d'un an à la réunion j'ai même pas nul
donc voilà ça ici
là aujourd'hui je déménage à trie bel
appartement franchement c'est tout va
bien quoi ma fille a vu ce temps mon
petit garçon à 4,1 du garçon il parle
voilà aujourd'hui j'ai tout j'ai tout à
oui là je suis plus que bien
[Musique]